with that let's welcome David Thank You
satinder it's really a great pleasure to
be here so today I'm going to talk about
alpha zero which is deep mines latest
deep reinforcement learning architecture
it's actually achieved superhuman level
in many games now without human
knowledge beyond the game rules and this
is joint work with many great
collaborators a deep mind that I listed
at the bottom there so gonna start with
the game of Go which is the oldest and
most deeply studied game in human
history it's been it's around 3,000
years old and it's played currently by
around 40 million active players around
the world so in some sense you can think
that it represents the pinnacle of human
knowledge in any game it's been studied
by professional players who've developed
this enormous pyramid of knowledge over
many many years and so in some sense it
makes a perfect testbed to really
understand how far we've come with our
machine learning and artificial
intelligence based approaches relative
to that the best that of human knowledge
it's also been viewed as a grand
challenge to artificial intelligence and
this is largely due to the enormous size
of the state space so this oft-cited
figure of around ten to the hundred and
seventy states in the game of go make it
very challenging for traditional search
based methods so I'm just gonna start by
visualizing what that search space looks
like so in the game of Go there's a
branching factor of around say 200 and
at each one of these positions that
you're in you have 200 possible actions
that could be taken and leading to new
positions where again there's 200 more
decisions that could be made and so
forth and and this actually lasts for
several hundred moves and so we actually
have something like 200 to the power of
200 possible sequences in the game tree
and so this really renders the game of
go completely intractable to traditional
search methods and as meant that
something new was required to make
progress so I'm going to start by
talking about the original version of
alphago
which became the first computer program
to defeat a human professional player
and then the first program to defeat a
human world champion so at the heart of
alphago are two convolutional
all networks that represent knowledge
about the game of Go so the first of
these is the policy network which is
illustrated here so the policy network
which we denoted by this green P in this
talk represents alphago's
recommendations of moves to play so in
each position it's fed in a
representation of the position as
different planes representing the board
such as where the black stones are where
the white stones are where the empty
intersections are and this is fed
through many convolutional layers to
process this position into increasingly
abstract features representing knowledge
about the game would go and finally this
is brought together into a policy
distribution over moves that actually
recommends which moves to play so in
this situation for example we can see
that that tall bar is suggesting that in
this particular position one particular
move is considered to be a very good
move and is suggested and recommended
with high probability whereas many of
the other moves such as playing in the
corner would have near zero probability
so this is how alphago recommends which
move to play the second neural network
in alphago is called the value network
and this represents alphago's positional
evaluation knowledge and essentially
what it does is it predicts the winner
of the game so again it takes a
representation of the position of the
game of go as an input it processes it
through a convolutional network but this
time it kind of takes that and it
aggregates all of that knowledge
together in a final layer that combines
this together into a single scalar value
between minus 1 and plus 1 where +1
means a prediction there of certain win
for alphago and minus 1 means a
prediction of certain loss so these
neural networks are a trained in alphago
and I'm going to represent a slightly
simplified representation here of the
training pipeline in alphago which is
based on a pipeline of classical machine
learning approaches and at the beginning
of this pipeline we start with a human
data set a data set of positions and for
each position is we have a label that
says what the move was that was chosen
by a strong human player and what we do
is we train our policy network first of
all by supervised learning to classify
that human move to say in this position
we would
I can network to predict the same move
that that human played in that
particular position and once we have
this policy network this policy network
P were able to play games against itself
using the policy network for now without
any steps at all absurd plays games
against itself the policy network
picking move for both players for both
black and white all the way through the
game until the end of the game at which
point we we have a winner of that game
and what we do is we then train our
value network this value network which
we indicate by V here this pink V we
train the value network by reinforcement
learning to predict the winner of the
game from each one of those positions so
from every position we would ask our
value network to correctly predict
predicts which of those two players
black or white will win when the policy
network plays against itself so that was
the original alphago arm training
pipeline and the main idea of alphago is
to really use the policy network and
value network to make search tractable
um so again we see here our kind of
cartoon representation of this enormous
search basin that we have in the game of
Go we're here we're just looking at a
cartoon where we have just two different
moves that are possible from each of
these small states but in reality there
will be several hundred moves and this
this tree would be would be vast and so
what can we do how can we make this
search tree more tractable using up
using our neural networks well the first
idea is to use the policy network to
reduce the the breadth of the search
tree so recall that the policy network
suggests moves to make in each position
and so can actually reduce the breadth
of this search by only considering moves
that are recommended by the policy
Network so instead of searching 200 or
so moves from each state we might
consider just a handful and just going
to expand that handful of moves in the
search tree to dramatically narrow the
set of arm
possible sequences that we need to
consider the second idea is to use the
value network to actually reduce the
depth of the search so the value network
predicts the winner of the game from any
position and so that means that we can
actually use the value network to
replace any subtree of our search tree
with a single number so that means that
we can actually instead of searching all
the way to the end of the game we can
truncate our sequence at a leaf node and
we can replace the subtree that we would
have had to search systematically all
the way to the end of the game we can
replace that whole search tree with a
single evaluation of our of our neural
network and this dramatically reduces
the the size of the search space that we
need to consider so in practice we
actually use a more sophisticated search
algorithm than that cartoon suggested
which is based on Monte Carlo tree
search and so I'm just going to briefly
illustrate how this works if you would
like more details you can you can read
the papers and so forth but the
algorithm proceeds in in three stages so
in the first stage the algorithm
traverses the tree from root to leaf
picking each node it picks a child based
on a kind of upper confidence rule to
decide which action it should select so
this rule actually selects actions that
have been evaluated most highly in pass
simulations that this Q value from each
node and it also prefers to choose
actions that the policy network likes
that's the Cu term the U term kind of is
a bonus term that includes
what the policy network thinks of the
move in the second stage once we've
actually traversed this this simulation
down to a leaf node we expand the leaf
node and evaluate this new node with
both the policy and the value networks
and finally in the third stage we back
up the evaluation so whatever this
evaluation was according to the value
Network we back that up through the
search tree so that every node we
maintain the mean evaluation from each
of those edges so each Q value there is
basically storing the mean evaluation
that it's seen from that point onwards
in the search at this process this
process Monte College research can very
effectively expand a very large search
tree by just considering that the most
important parts of that search tree get
expanded and it systematically kind of
gets deeper and deeper and deeper but
I'm in a very selective fashion so only
considers the important parts of the
search tree so we applied alphago
in a in a match against the winner of 18
world titles Lisa doll so he's widely
considered to be their greatest player
of recent decades and this match was
played between alphago and and Lisa doll
in 2016 and alphago actually won the
match by four games to one but that one
game that we lost actually highlighted
some of the deficiencies of alphago
so in particular we found that in some
kinds of position
alphago can systematically miss evaluate
misunder
down those positions we used to call
these delusions it would enter into a
type of position where it failed to
understand what was going on there and
that kind of misunderstanding could
persist for many different positions
throughout the game so it could persist
for 10 or 20 or 30 moves and we really
wanted to understand this and this led
to us actually progressing further to
try and understand and progress alphago
towards something which could play much
more strongly without exhibiting these
kinds of weaknesses and this led to a
subsequent version of alphago which we
called alphago master
so for alphago master we trained new
policy networks and new value networks
using much deeper state-of-the-art
residual networks and using them many
more iterations of reinforcement
learning with more precise kinds of
evaluation and so alphago master we
played earlier this year against the
worlds ranked number one player co-chair
and we won three games to zero but
perhaps more encouragingly than that
still we played online in a series of 60
matches 60 games against that the
top-ranked human players in the world
and we won by 60 games to zero so I
think what this shows is that principled
reinforcement learning combined with
principled deep learning can address
these kinds of systemic delusion that we
we saw that just by by sticking to our
principles and doing things just further
and better we can actually start to
address things which which people
believed at the time would require are
new kinds of research but really all the
principles are already there we just
needed to do it do it very well so I'm
now going to move on to a more recent
artwork which we call alphago zero so
the goal of alphago zero is to take
every form of human knowledge that went
into the previous version alphago and
remove it from the training process
except for the rules themselves so the
idea of alphago zero is really to learn
to play the game of go tabula rasa
starting from first principles and
really understanding and discovering
knowledge about the game completely for
itself without any human actually having
to tell it the kind of things to do or
any human data to guide it or anything
else like that and so the differences
between alphago zero in the previous
alphago are essentially listed on this
slide
the first and most important is that it
news
no human data whatsoever so it learns
solely by self play by playing a games
against itself and training by
reinforcement learning starting from
completely random games so in other
words we initialize on your own network
to random weights and it plays games
against itself starting with those
random weights so it knows nothing about
the game and everything else is
discovered from there onwards the second
difference is that alphago 0 uses
absolutely no handcrafted features
there's nothing in there beyond the raw
board so all it sees when it takes us
out with the only thing that the neural
network sees and received as an input is
actually a representation of the raw
board so it justice has a plain saying
you know whether there's black stones in
this position and plain saying whether
there's white stones in this position
and that's it that's all it sees but
there are some additional differences
one of the most notable ones is that we
actually unified the policy network and
value network into a single neural
network again based on a
state-of-the-art residual network and
this actually helped to regularize the
network and make it much more robust
against the kind of overfitting which is
possible to see if you just have a value
network trained by itself for example in
addition alphago zero actually uses a
simpler search so in previous Monte
Carlo tree search --is and to an extent
the previous version of alphago there
was actually these randomized Monte
Carlo rollouts in other words when you
reach the leaf node it used to do
something where would run a random game
all the way to the end and then evaluate
the that node based on how well that
random rollout performed and so you'd be
in this situation where if random games
tended to win more often you would start
to believe that that that was a very
effective position so actually in
alphago zero we removed those rollouts
altogether we really wanted to have the
simplest possible approach with the
minimal level of knowledge so we removed
those and we only use the neural network
to evaluate positions and maybe one of
the principles which were after an
alphago zero is this idea that by by
doing less by actually removing
complexity from the algorithm enables us
to actually become more general we want
to have something which can not only be
applied to the game of Go which after
all is just one domain we want to get at
the heart of what it means to really
we want to have something which can
really learn from first principles
potentially in any domain of course the
game would grow as a first step but it's
a challenging first step and if we can
understand how to learn from first
principles to discover knowledge and and
reach the highest levels of human
capabilities there maybe this is
something which has more capability to
transfer to other domains so this is the
goal less complexity more generality so
I'm now going to describe the algorithm
which we actually used in alphago zero
so the main idea is that alphago
actually becomes its own teacher so in a
sense what we want is we want to have
the highest quality data to train our
algorithm on we want to train on your
networks from really really high quality
data really high-quality move selections
and really high quality outcomes and the
best possible data that we can get our
hands on actually comes from playing
alphago against itself so the idea is
really to do the following that from
each position we execute a Monte Carlo
tree search using our current neural
network so this policy and value
combined Network P and V there that kind
of guides this this tree search to
suggest ultimately at the end of the
tree search a move is suggested we play
that move we run another search play
another move and so forth all the way
until we've completed a game when that
game is completed its scored and we
determine the winner of the game the
next stages we train a new neural
network so the policy part of the
network is updated to predict the move
that was actually played by alphago
itself in each position so this new
policy network P Prime from each of
these positions that were actually
reached in this game we want to to
basically get the neural network to
predict the move that was actually
played we want the raw neural network to
directly predict the action that was
chosen by an entire MCTS so in other
words we want to kind of compress
everything which was achieved using look
ahead into the new neural network so
that can distill all of that knowledge
into its direct behavior at the same
time we also train a new a new value
Network so this is the value part of our
neural network and that at the same time
gets trained to predict the winner of
this game so at the end of this again
we're looking at this game that was
played by self play and from each
the positions that was reached during
this game we would like to predict the
winner of that game so and we simply
train our network to to predict both the
winner and also the move that was played
so we have this joint training rule with
these just two terms to it and a simple
regularization and that's it
that's the whole of alphago zero and
finally once we have this we iterate the
procedure so we now have a new policy
and value network and this could be used
in the next iteration of of alphago zero
and the key idea is that each time we
iterate this process we end up with an
even stronger player and because we have
a stronger player it generates even
higher quality data so each time we
improve the quality of the search it
means that we actually end up with
outcomes which are more indicative of
optimal play and then we can train our
new generation of neural networks based
on those higher quality searches this
higher quality move selection and the
higher quality outcomes and this process
can be repeated it almost indefinitely
and intends to lead to just stronger and
stronger play so if we relate this to
what's been done before in reinforcement
learning this relates to a very
well-known idea in reinforcement
learning which is the classic policy
iteration algorithm the twist here is
that we actually incorporate alphago
search inside the policy iteration so we
call this search based policy iteration
and the idea is that you know in a
policy iteration we interleave two
phases there's policy improvement where
the action selection is somehow made
stronger and then there's a policy
evaluation where the quality of these
selected actions is evaluated and the
whole idea of policy iteration is that
if you alternate between these two
stages you end up getting a stronger and
stronger policy which ends up eventually
ideally approximating the optimal policy
and so what we do in in alphago zero is
we actually use search based policy
improvement so the idea is that instead
of say using a greedy policy improvement
as it's traditionally done in RL we use
the whole of our search as the policy
improvement so in other words we start
off with our raw neural network which
picks an action and we massively improve
that policy in one shot
by running a search and the action which
is picked by the search is typically
much much stronger than the action which
was selected by the raw neural network
because it's incorporated all of this
look ahead in a
we incorporate search into the policy
evaluation so we used search based
policy evaluation and what this means is
that we play ourself play games with
alphago actually running it search at
every step and so what this does is it
means that we're actually evaluating the
improved policy we're not evaluating the
raw neural network we're evaluating the
improved policy and this gives us very
very high quality outcomes which enables
us to really in every step have very
high quality data that leads to very
precise training signals for our neural
networks so this all relates to prior
work command and also recent work that's
been done elsewhere in NRL starting with
McHale lega lega darkus in 2003 who had
a paper on classification based
reinforcement learning but in all of
this some other work what's happened is
there's been a focus on the search based
policy improvement in some sense but
there hasn't been previously this idea
of search based policy evaluation and
that turned out to be absolutely
critical in alphago zero that this was
the step if you had to pick out the one
step which led to you know thousands of
you know improvement in performance is
that second one but the overall
algorithm is very effective and seems to
be rather robust and reliable as we'll
see so if we look here a learning curve
this is a learning curve starting from
zero knowledge and running for 40 days
so time here is the x-axis it's actually
we measure in time this corresponds if
you want to know to around 30 million
actual games but actually for us as
developers time is the thing which
matters because this is what determines
how many iterations of the algorithm we
can run and as developers and
researchers that's there that's the
thing you altom utley care about and on
the y-axis we have the elo rating ela
ratings of their communist form of
evaluation in games like chess and go
and so forth so what we see here is that
it started off playing completely
randomly at the start of this timeline
so really had completely randomized
initial weights but after three days it
already surpassed the version of alphago
which we call alpha goalie that defeated
Lisa Dahl in 2016 so that happened in
just 72 hours after 21 days we saw that
alphago zero surpassed alphago master
this previous best version that we'd had
and that defeated human players by 60
games to nail
and eventually after 40 days we ended up
with our strongest person of alphago
zero although was still continuing to
improve so that potentially it could
have been left her to climb even more so
if we actually try to evaluate alphago
and look at it and try and quantify what
these improvements really mean we
started out with some kind of previous
state of the art on this elos scale
which were previous programs and one way
to understand this which is maybe more
understandable to to us in the audience
here is by instead of looking a low
ratings we can look at the number of
stones of difference between programs so
this roughly says how many extra moves
one program could give another and still
win and so between the original version
of alphago which we published in our
first nature article and the previous
state-of-the-art was around a four stone
difference and this is the version that
defeated the European champion by five
games to nil we subsequently developed
the version alpha goalie that defeated
the world champion Lisa doll by four
games to one and that was around three
stones stronger than the previous
version although you have to take all of
these these stone evaluations with a
pinch of salt because it turns out the
we we do very very well at defeating
weaker versions of ourselves because
we've essentially trained by self play
and therefore we are better at beating
previous versions of ourselves than we
would necessarily be at beating some
held our other program and from there we
went on to develop alphago master which
was another three stone stronger and
this was the version that beat the top
professional 60 games to nail and
finally we ended up with something
around 5,000 elo which was the alphago
zero and this was the one which was
trained completely from first principles
so all of the knowledge had been removed
so one of the nice things about alphago
and alphago zero particular is that it
can actually learn to discover our human
knowledge for itself so it starts from
random weights which means that
everything it learns it learns for a
reason it learns because it finds some
pattern which it has discovered is
important in games of self play and so
over time it really starts to understand
the game and we can really think of this
as some form of understanding it's
developed the intuitions that are
important for it to be able to evaluate
and play this game effectively and so in
particular we we analyze the actual
opening patterns these are called joseki
and the game of go these are like corner
sequences that the strong human players
used to to play out town positions in
different in different situations and
and all of these known opening patterns
or joseki were discovered as training
proceeded so it started from nothing but
as training proceeded this is like a
timeline we see here starting from zero
hours and going up to 72 hours we see
that it started to pick out really
well-known joseki that humans play but
what was interesting is that some of
them then get dumped discarded that you
know starts to play them but after a
while it discovers that actually it's
found some better variation and it
discards them it prefers our new
patterns and new ideas which actually
human players didn't necessarily know
about and so this is now adding to the
knowledge base and enabling humans to
play in new ways so finally I'd like to
talk about the most recent work so this
was just published a couple of days ago
this is a something we called alpha zero
and really I think this comes from the
idea that an algorithm it can't really
be claimed to be general unless it's
applied to multiple domains apps of
course the motivation for alphago zero
was to be general by using less
knowledge but we really wanted to
demonstrate that fact and so we wants to
apply the same algorithm up to three
different games and so we applied it not
just to go but to the games of chess and
shogi so the game of chess has a lower
complexity than go but it's still a
really considerable challenge there's
around 10 to the 48 states however chess
is interesting to us for very different
reasons actually to go so computer chess
is actually the most studied arguably
the most studied domain in the history
of artificial intelligence so it turns
out they're actually the pioneers of
computer science are people like Babbage
Turing Shannon and von Neumann were
absolutely fascinated by computer chess
and developed sometimes just on paper
the very first algorithms to play
computer to play chess with a computer
and subsequently chess became the
Drosophila of artificial intelligence
the kind of arm the platform that
everyone used the fruit fly in other
words there everyone used to conduct
their experiments on four decades of
research and actually this research
develops enormous progress and huge
numbers of ideas were thrown in and
programs got stronger and stronger and
stronger and culminating in these highly
specialized systems which were very
success
in chess and ultimately that the program
deep-blue from IBM defeated Garry
Kasparov in 1997 but in the 20 years
since then the state-of-the-art
continued to progress to a level where
they're now indisputably human I think
they're the top programs are something
like 600 elos stronger than the deep
blue was so this gives us a you know
really fantastic case study of a domain
where where the expertise of humours has
been leveraged and specialized to really
produce the best that can possibly be be
done in that one domain so we also
looked at the game of shogi so this is
Japanese chess and shogi is interesting
to us because it's some both harder than
chess in terms of computation so it uses
a larger board but also it has a much
larger and more interesting action space
and that's because in the game of
Japanese chess shogi when you capture a
piece it actually kind of flips around
and becomes one of your own pieces and
then on your move you can place it down
at any position on the board and this
really blows up the action space and
leads to enormous be complicated
tactical sequences and what what this
means is that actually in the game of
shogi the the strongest computers
despite a lot of effort I've actually
only recently achieved human world
champion level and so it becomes an
interesting case study for us and so
both of these cases for chess and and
shogi the state-of-the-art engines are
based on alpha-beta search so alpha-beta
search is a form of minimax search where
where the minimax optimal solution is
found by a kind of search tree and that
search has been that alpha beta search
has been augmented by enormous amounts
of knowledge so in particular what goes
into it typically is a handcrafted
evaluation function that's been tuned by
human grandmasters over many many years
the whole history of computer chess has
led to these grandmasters creating these
very complicated and specific features
which enable just programs to
effectively and efficiently evaluate
positions and in addition they have a
huge number of search extensions that
are highly optimised to the particular
game of chess so I think it's useful to
actually make this concrete so we can
actually start to dissect one of the top
programs so he'll look at the program
stockfish which was the 2016 well
computer chess champion
and this is a really beautifully
engineered program with a vast array of
specialized components in it and what
I'm going to put up is is a list here in
which every item represents a major
component of stockfish and most of these
components that would also you'd also
find in other top chess programs or
you'd find equivalent components and
each one of these items kind of you can
think of as corresponding to potentially
years of research in the computer chess
community to get this idea or this
particular search extension right and
the majority of them aren't some of them
are very general purpose but the
majority of them are actually used a lot
of specialized knowledge which is
specific to the game of chess and so we
would like to replace this with a system
which learns for itself and which can
therefore be applied to other domains
and so if we look at the equivalent to
anatomy of alpha zero we can essentially
remove every single one of those
components and replace them with
principled ideas based on self play
reinforcement learning and self play
Monte Carlo search only and literally
there are no none of these in there
there's no transposition table there's
no opening book no endgame tablebases no
no extensions so then the question is
how well can an approach which is really
very pure actually do compare to these
traditional approaches which have been
optimized for decades well I think to
answer that question we really need to
understand some of the properties of
chess and shogi compared to the game of
go because one of the reasons we wants
to study this is to see whether the kind
of success we saw and go was specific to
go or whether it would actually
generalize to a game with very different
properties so for example chess unlike
go doesn't have perfect translational
invariance that's because you've got
pawns which can move in different ways
of different parts of the board they
promote it their eighth rank and they
move two steps from the second rank and
things like this they don't have this
kind of arm perfect locality that you
have in the game of go so the game of Go
the rules are very locally they're
defined in terms of the adjacencies of
the stones to to the next stone whereas
the rules of chess are defined in terms
of like Queen moves which can jump you
from one side of the board to the other
and so these first two properties may be
things which are which make which make
training more amenable to convolutional
neural networks for example
the third point is is symmetry that that
alphago actually exploited symmetry and
the original version because the game of
go is perfectly symmetric with this
eight fold dihedral symmetry whereas
chess actually is not symmetric because
there are there are there are symmetry
breaking things in it there are so
there's pawns always move forward and
there are castling rules which are
different on both sides of the board so
we actually threw out all of the
symmetry augmentations that were used in
alphago and we want this to be as
general as possible the action space is
also more interesting in chess and shogi
because it has these kind of compound
actions where you pick up a piece and
then you move it somewhere else and so
it's not just like I'm pointing to one
particular location on the board there's
this compound structure to it and
finally in the game of Go there are no
drawers and this means that you actually
have a binary outcome meaning that the
value function actually has this very
nice interpretation as a probability of
winning I mean it may be that that led
to particularly nice dynamics for their
game um and so for chess we actually
have draws in fact there are so many
draws that they tend to dominate in
high-level chess play particularly with
computers and it's believed that the
optimal outcome of chess is a draw and
so we really needed to evaluate
something which took account of all
possible outcomes and we chose to use
the expected value and as per a standard
value function where the -1 for a loss
plus 1 for a win and 0 for a draw and so
the question is whether we need to do
anything different for all of these
properties but despite all of these
difference we applied exactly the same
algorithm as I've described earlier in
the talk using the same network
architecture and the same settings for
all games forgo chess and shogi so if we
look at how it does this is the learning
curves for the three games so first of
all again we see that this x-axis
represents a kind of measure of time
this is now the number of training steps
so this is the thousands of mini batches
which get updated by the training
algorithm so so this is a hundred
thousand training mini-batches 200,000
mini batters and so forth and the y-axis
is again an e low rating which should be
interpreted differently for each of
these games for example in shogi there
and go that the scale seems to be more
elongated whereas in chess it gets more
compressed because of the prevalence of
draws and so we see that in chess we
actually starting from scratch
and starting from random within just
four hours around 200,000 armed steps
outperformed this previous world
champion stockfish in the game of shogi
it took just around a hundred thousand
steps or two hours to surpass the world
champion in in the computer shogi
Association and in the game of go as a
control we compared to the previous
version of alpha zero and actually
despite not using symmetries we actually
learned to outperform the previous
version of alpha zero and and not only
that but we defeated the alpha goalie
the versions defeated Lisa Dahl in just
around just a few hundred thousand steps
here so around eight hours of training
so we also played once these were fully
trained we played matches against the
previous state-of-the-art in chess
showed you and go and so what you see
here is that in a hundred game match
against the world champion stockfish we
didn't lose a single game when we played
against the current world champion in
shogi we won around 90 percent of the
games and finally we were able to defeat
the previous version of alphago zero
using equivalent network architecture so
we also wanted to look at the
scalability of alpha zeroes Monte Carlo
tree search and we really wants to
compare this to the alpha beta search
engines they've been used in previous
programs um and this is interesting
because alpha beta search has dominated
in these domains for 40 years now and
they've been many studies that suggested
there actually MCTS or any other
algorithm than alpha beta could not be
competitive and yet what we see here is
that not only did we outperform these
other programs but the MCTS actually
scaled up more effectively than alpha
beta so the more thinking time we give
the program the more it starts to
outperform stockfish and chess and elmo
and go and not only that but it actually
used around a thousand times fewer
evaluations per second in these programs
so stockfish evaluates around 70 million
positions per second whereas alpha zero
is picking out just something like 80
thousand positions per second
and this is interesting because actually
when Shannon was looking into computer
chess he proposed that are actually two
ways to consider planning he called them
type A and type B he said the type A
algorithms would essentially be doing
brute-force search where they'd be
systematically evaluating every kind of
position you can come across and that
type B algorithms would be using a more
brain like system where they would
actually be carefully deciding which of
these positions should be expanded next
based on an understanding of what's
going on in the position and it turned
out that for decades these type a these
kind of more systematic searchers have
dominated but it looks like what's
happening here is perhaps something more
like that original spirit of type B
whether by despite evaluating orders of
magnitude fewer positions if you
actually evaluate those in the right way
and you're very careful about what you
evaluate you can actually get better
performance and better scalability so we
think that one reason why m tts is so
effective compared to alpha beta when
you start to use these approximate
function approximate is like neural
networks is that like a neural network
inevitably is going to have some kind of
approximation error in it and what
happens when you do an alpha beta sir so
alpha B to search the kind of minimax
search so you can think of it as like a
great big glorified max operator
although it's alternating with mins as
well and what happens is that will pick
out the biggest errors in your function
approximator and propagate them right to
the root whereas MCTS is actually
averaging over the evaluations that you
have and so this actually tends to
cancel out these errors that you have in
your search and we just speculating at
this point but this may be one of the
reasons why MCTS can be so effective
when it's combined with with deep
function approximate errs so as in the
game of Go we see that alpha 0 also
discovered human chess knowledge for
itself so what we did was he actually
picked out the 12 most common human
openings that were played we all them
all the openings that were played more
than a hundred thousand times in our
online database I've shown the first set
here and we checked out how often alpha
zero played these games during self play
and that's this plot that you see here
it's the frequency by which it was
played during games of self play and
what we see is that alpha zero played
most of these variations extensively but
it ended up dismissing some of these
variations like the French defense later
on as it discoverer
and starts to prefer different
variations in addition we also tried
playing a match against Doc fish from
each one of these openings to make sure
that we could actually perform robustly
and we hadn't just discovered like one
exploit against Doc fish and we actually
beat stop fish robustly from all of
these twelve positions so it just wants
to conclude by just talking about what
happens when we move beyond games so of
course the idea of alpha zero is
actually to be able to take us beyond go
and into the realm of general-purpose
reinforcement learning now at the moment
it's still early steps and I would of
course hesitate to say that that the
real world is anything like the game of
Go or the game of chess but nevertheless
one thing which we're very interested in
is trying to progress these methods to
general-purpose deep reinforcement
learning ideas and so what we've been
looking at are deep mind in general and
not necessarily using the kind of
planning methods that we saw in alpha
zero but using a whole host a whole
array of different approaches these deep
reinforcement learning algorithms so for
example here is one of the
state-of-the-art algorithms we have
which is called unreal and which is
based on a much more model free approach
which is learning to play in these deep
MindLab domains by learning about a
whole host of different targets and I'll
actually be talking about this
particular example in a couple of data
the hierarchical reinforcement learning
workshop but what we'd like to do is
keep progressing beyond these games and
the key idea and the thing which I think
I want to emphasize from this talk if
more than anything else is that the more
we take out specialized knowledge the
more we enable our algorithms to be
general-purpose and the more we can hope
and start to believe that they will
actually transfer into something which
will be helpful and successful in
domains beyond the ones for which it was
designed and tested and I think there's
a lesson there which is you know every
time you specialize something you
actually hurt your your generalization
ability so that's really it I just wants
to conclude by asking for questions and
I'll put this online but there's some
links if you're interested in any more
resources and games and so forth thank
you very much
okay so there are microphones scattered
in the aisles if you'd like to come up
and ask questions we can have a few now
hello thank you for the presentation was
wonderful one of the things that I had
seen that has been worked on in chess
was that even though computers were on
superhuman level but when the and
analysis that computer was doing was
given to the human the human plus
computer could outperform to hear the
computer by itself so I wonder if you
have done any that of that sort of
analysis to see if given this type of
reinforcement learning solution that we
have it humans still have a new
perspective a way that the human
intelligence works that could add to the
solution and it could actually ask
perform alpha zero itself so that's a
great question I mean I should say for
chess in particular we literally just
put up these results a couple of days
ago so they're brand-new only haven't
had really a chance to perform these
kind of extensive investigations I think
I think the question of these centur
programs which combine human and and a
machine together is very interesting
maybe I can just I don't want to
speculate on what would happen because I
genuinely don't know but I think maybe
one comment would be which I can't pass
on is the reaction of the chess
community to the style of alpha zero and
the way it plays chess and the reaction
has been that it plays in a much more
human way than previous chess programs
so actually plays in a way where it
tends to play quite aggressively freely
this kind of open style which which
humans tend to favor but of course with
the additional precision of computer
abilities and I think in addition to
that it's found this new style which
hadn't been seen before it can do things
like um be quite free about its ideas
about when when material is worthwhile
so it will for example give up a night
not because it sees that it can it can
win back that material within its search
tree but because it's understood within
it within its deep understanding of
what's going on into position that it
can exert some advantage over the
opponents it's worth more than a night
we have an example and the games that we
put out where it it takes more than 50
moves before it wins back the the
material from this night sacrifice for
example but yeah I think interesting
question thank you okay two more
questions darling so you mentioned that
the only human knowledge that you
embedded into alphago's serum was the
rules of the game so I guess I have a
more this like basic question what are
the output moves represented and then
how do you prevent the network from
making an invalid both okay so so first
of all yeah I didn't have a chance to
explain but though we we have to use so
that when I say we use the rules of the
game the rules of the game includes some
basic encoding of those rules into the
inputs and some basic decoding of the
action from from back in to actually
playing a move in the game so what we do
at specifically in the game of chess is
that we have well we tried a couple of
things actually we tried a flap encoding
which also worked by the way we just
have a flat vector distribution and we
also had a spatial representation which
had basically where we used the piece
that you pick up was spatially encoded
and the place that you put it down was
was the particular plane that you use so
is that knowledge well it's it's a way
to encode the rules you need some way to
interface between what the Machine does
and what's going on in the game and so I
think to me that becomes part of what
the rule definitions are I think the
fact that it also works with a flat
representation suggests that we're not
too sensitive to that and that's
something which we substitute between
the different games for the legal moves
yeah that's also included in knowledge
of the rule so we do exclude illegal
moves because and that's helpful in
chess because you have a very large
action space yeah so question for maybe
out yep nice talk I would like to know
some more about your experiments the
curve you show don't have error bars is
it because the error bars are too small
to see or are we seeing just one run
chosen at random so these runs are very
expensive so this is just one run per
game I mean this is using a large number
of CPUs on Google compute so you've
never run two experiments on this it's
only you
run only one experimental history of
your of your project so we are reporting
a single experiment here we have
ourselves run multiple experiments and
it's very reproducible so we get the
same results essentially every time
thank you yeah okay thank you very much
[Applause]